herzlichen dank für die einladung ich
freue mich sehr heute über reinholz
sprechen zu dürfen der titel lautet
rhein rollers moralische gefühle kann
deutung oder kann kritik ja ich möchte
aber auch vorwiegend das was vielleicht
auch alles unsinn ist was ich sagen
werde also man kann anderer meinung sein
natürlich aber ich freue mich auf jeden
fall meine gedanken vorstellen zu dürfen
ich habe die werde mich vor allen dingen
auf die den zweiten bank von reinholz
briefen über die kante philosophie
konzentrieren
den habe ich vor circa acht jahren
entdeckt und er hat mich dann schon sehr
elementare begleitet während meiner
auseinandersetzung mit bitcoins
moralphilosophie deshalb freut es mich
heute mal meine gedanken dazu mit ihnen
teilen zu dürfen also in meinem vortrag
werde ich erstens eben die frage stellen
welche position vertritt reinhold mit
blick auf das moralische gefühl welche
thesen vertritt er und anschließend die
frage stellen wie sich cantz positionen
dazu verhält ob es da übereinstimmung
gibt oder abweichungen also die agenda
sieht so aus es gibt zwei teile
im ersten teil spreche ich über reinhold
und zwar seine thesen über das
moralische gefühl durch wobei ich
erstens die frage in den blick nehmen ob
es sich um ein motivationsgrund handelt
nach reinhold zweitens das moralische
gefühle als überzeugungs grund vorstelle
also schon auch den schwerpunkt setze
auf die funktionen und die stellung des
moralischen gefühls in reinholz riefen
und im zweiten teil dann die frage
stellen ob es sich eben um eine kam
deutung oder ihr um eine kann kritiker
nennen könnte und dort erstens exotisch
und zweitens systematisch einige
überlegungen vorstellen
kommt also zum ersten teil und der frage
ob es sich um ein motivationsgrund
handeln können sie mir gesagt ich bin
ziemlich vor allen dingen auf den
zweiten band der brief und insbesondere
auf den siebten brief der dem titel
direkt über den bisher verkannten
unterschied zwischen dem uneigennützigen
und dem eigennützigen triebe und
zwischen diesen beiden trieben und dem
willen
ich habe den ersten teil hier mal blau
markiert weil gerade der 17 brief
natürlich auch prominent bekannt dafür
ist das was rein dort und im achter
brief dann ja den begriff der
willensfreiheit auch diskutiert und dort
eben auch stark abweicht von kants
positionen und ich denke aber dass man
hier diesen siebten rief gewissermaßen
zwei teilen kann und so wie auch die
überschrift zweigeteilt ist dem ersten
teil da die überschrift für geld über
den bisher verkannten unterschied
zwischen dem uneigennützigen dem
eigennützigen triebe und das rheingold
in diesem ersten teil eben vor allem das
moralische gefühle oder die frage nach
der moralischen triebfeder thematisieren
und zwar stellt er den bisherigen streit
vor zwischen den vertretern der
verschiedenen philosophischen richtungen
und kritisiert dass es sich um ein wort
streit gehandelt habe ein wort streit
über die fragen erstens ob es überhaupt
eine uneigennützige triebfeder gebe oder
nicht also eine existenzfrage
und zweitens ob dieselbe von der
allgemein anerkannten eigennützigen
wesentlich verschieden sei oder nicht
also da eine differenz frage und er
vertritt wie eben auch schon mit ihnen
dieses briefs angekündigt dass der
bisherige unterschied verkannt worden
sei dass es sich um mord gehandelt habe
insofern allen positionen ein
gemeinsames missverständnis zugrunde
gelegen habe sie würden alle
voraussetzen dass eine triebfeder immer
in einem
lust und unlust bestehen müsse so und
aus diesem grund so fertig reinholz sei
bisher der unterschied verkannt worden
dann aber kam die wende
dadurch kann die wendung im streit ich
kann's unterscheidung zwischen
verschiedenen arten von wohlgefallen die
ermöglicht nach 1 wollte nämlich jetzt
was man wesentliche unterscheidung
treffen kann also verschiedene arten von
vergnügen unterscheiden kann und nicht
nur graduell zwischen zwischen gefühlen
oder vergnügen unterscheiden kann also
ich muss noch mal kurz technologisch
sagen das ist etwas sauber wie ich hier
etwas unsauber leider wie hier ein
nordire
er spricht von vergnügen ich glaube
allerdings dass es sich beziehen lässt
auf die frage nach dem moralischen
sittlichen gefühlen ja das ist also ich
verwende das synonym ihr vergnügen
gefühle lust und unlust und südliches
gefühl und moralisches gefühl so das nur
am rande
also die wendung bekommen durch kann es
theorie der oder kann es unterscheidung
von verschiedenen arten von wohl
gefallen wobei unter wohlgefallen rein
läuft die übereinstimmung zwischen dem
vorstellen den subjekten und dem
vorgestellten objekte versteht und
dieser übereinstimmung entsprechend
beurteilen wir etwas als angenehm
nämlich dann wenn ein vergnügen vorher
geht im unterschied zu dem prädikat
zeitlich gut dass wir einen gegenstand
dann zu schreiben wenn es uns um seiner
selbst willen gefällt und in diesem fall
also wenn es sich um das sittliche
wohlgefallen handelt folgt das vergnügen
auf das urteil dass etwas wirklich gut
ist um seiner selbst willen so und durch
diese unterscheidung sei es eben möglich
jetzt im wesentlichen unterschied
zwischen der eigennützigen und der
uneigennützigen oder dem uneigennützigen
vergnügen zu begründen
ausgehend von dieser wendung
argumentiert reinhold jetzt mit blick
auf die frage ob es sich bei diesem um
eigenen vergnügen oder in den
südlichen gefühl sichtlichem
wohlgefallen rund um die uneigennützige
triebfeder handeln kann oder nicht
und grundlage hierzu bildet eine
unterscheidung von 2 es hat mal zwei
installierung von sichtlichem
wohlgefallen nämlich erstens dem wohl
gefallen an der gesetzmäßigkeit einer
handlung die geschehen soll
also sozusagen an an dem gebot und
zweitens was wohl gefallen an der
gesetzmäßigkeit der handlung die
geschehen ist also im ersten fall sind
wir uns der pflichtbewusst im zweiten
fall erfüllen wir die pflicht und an
beiden können wir eben ein ziemliches
wohl gefallen wobei das können wir
endlich das wohlgefallen empfinden
ich habe das hier mal kurz als ws und
wie also die handlung geschehen soll
mit blick auf dieses wohlgefallen
argumentiert reinhold nun dass das nicht
die eigentliche triebfeder sein kann
weil dann das wohlgefallen alle daraus
folgende handlung wieder nur auf ein
vergnügen beruhen würde und dann würde
es sich eben um ein wort ohne begriff
handeln wie er sagt also die sittliche
handlung würde dann sozusagen nach nach
dieser definition ist wohl gefallen
würde dann sozusagen pathologisch
verursacht werden nämlich durch dieses
uneigennützige vergnügen und daneben
keine sichtliche handlung mehr sein
können die um ihrer selbst willen
geschätzt wird
mit blick auf das wohl gefallen an der
handlung die geschieden ist also an der
gesetzmäßig gesetzmäßigen anlagen wie
geschehen ist argumentieren dass dieses
wohl gefallen nicht der grund sein kann
für die wirklichkeit dieser
gesetzmäßigen handlung weil es eben was
seine voraussetzt
also das wäre ein zirkel dann würde man
würde man behaupten dass die folge eben
zugleich auch der grund sein und das
geht aus diesem grund nicht so und dann
kommt kein hund nach dieser
argumentation zu dem schluss das
uneigennützige vergnügen ist folge
nicht gründen der selbstbestimmung durch
gesetz welches weder durch vergnügen zum
gesetz gemacht noch durch dasselbe zur
ausübung gebracht wird eben auf der
grundlage von diesem verständnis vom
südlichen wohlgefallen und insofern
denke ich kann man hier die die
schlussfolgerung ziehen dass das das
moralische gefühle oder das sittliche
gefühl nach reinhold kein keine
motivierende funktion erfüllt
andererseits taucht das sittliche gefühl
bahrain wohl noch in einem anderen
kontext auf nämlich als überzeugungs
grund dann möchte ich jetzt als zweites
darauf eingehen und zwar in dem kontext
der unterscheidung zwischen der gemeinde
ziemlich in den gemeinden verstanden um
einen menschenverstand und der
philosophierenden vernunft möchte ich
kurz einen exkurs machen und auf den
zweiten band der beiträge ein gehen
überdies auf das erste kapitel über den
unterschied zwischen dem gesunden
verstanden und der philosophierende
vernunft dort beschreibt reinhold das
verhältnis mich sehr schön zwischen
diesen beiden erkenntnis zugängen als
eine abhängigkeit im sinne
wechselseitigen korrektur schreibt
irrtümern des gemeindevorstandes werden
durch gründlichere einsichten der
philosophierenden vernunft ebenso oft
als irrtümer von dieser durch gesunde
überzeugungen von jedem jenem aufgehoben
ja und darüber hinaus über diese
wechselseitige korrektur hinaus stellt
er die urteile des gemeindevorstandes
sehr positiv da behauptet dass die
teilweise mehr wahrheit enthalten als
die firmen vernunft und schreit sie
gehen den urteilen der philosophierenden
vernunft vorher begleiten die selbe und
berichtigen läutern und ergänzen die
unvollkommen begriffe so hier nochmal
die gegenüberstellung also die
philosophierende vernunft beschäftigt
sich nach einer und mit dem letzten
gründen der erfahrung sie bringt
deutlichkeit indem sie die abstrakte
bedeutung der wörter aufzeigt
und in diese abstraktion auch immer
weiter fortschreitet eben auf der suche
oder auf dem weg zu den letzten gründen
der erfahrung und tendenziell lässt sich
hier um eine begriffliche urteile beim
gemeinden gesunden menschenverstand oder
der beschäftigt sich hingegen mit den
tatsachen der erfahrung
er bringt klarheit ihrer mit schreibt in
dem man den worten eine konkrete
bedeutung gibt und es handelt sich um
gefühls basierte urteile und das ist
jetzt auch der punkt der eben
interessant ist für die frage nach der
funktion des wirklichen gefühlen
reinholz briefen da man dort ganz klar
eben auch diese verbindung findet
zwischen den gemeinden gesunde
menschenverstand und dem sittlichen
gefühl
insoferne dort vertritt dass in diesen
gefühls basierten urteilen unserer moral
bewusstsein begründet liegt und insofern
bezeichnet weil dort das kindliche
gefühl oder die wirklichen gefühle als
überzeugungs grundsätzlichen überzeugung
des grund hier ist ein zitat dazu ein
recht landeten wie ferne pflicht und
recht lediglich in den von allen
personen unabhängigen gesetz der
praktischen vernunft gegründet sind
insofern können sie sich im bewusstsein
ursprünglich keineswegs rechtsbegriffe
sondern nur durch gefühle ankündigen und
zwar nur durch solche gefühle die von
allen durch physische eindrücke
erzeugten empfindungen wesentlich
verschieden sind und die den einzigen
praktischen von einem unabhängigen und
allgemeingültigen überzeugungs grund für
das sittengesetz rollator ich ausmachen
unter dem zeitlichen gefühl versteht
reinhold hier erstens das bewusstsein
der übereinstimmung oder des
widerspruches einer winds handlung mit
dem sittengesetz dass ich in dem gefühls
vermögen ankündigt
und zweitens eben ein überzeugungs grund
wobei überzeugung beschreibt er als für
wahr halten also es handelt sich um ein
grund dafür dass wir den begriff von ihm
ging von einem gegenstand in diesem fall
dem der sinnlichkeit das prädikat war
beilegen
und ja insofern das moralische gefühl
dass endlich gefühl diese funktion hat
als überzeugungs grund oder ich
verstehen so dass das das umso wichtiger
ist insofern eben die philosophierende
vernunft relativ skeptisch auch
darstellt beziehungsweise ja auch
realistisch nämlich eben hervorhebt dass
wir dass wir wenn wir wieder so vielen
einfach sehr zum zweifeln neigen und
auch irrtums anfällig sind und das
bewahrt vor diesem hintergrund das
kindliche gefühl dringend brauchen um
uns sagen als moralisches objekte nicht
zu verlieren und nicht zu moralischen
skeptikern zu werten
also er schreibt ohne ersichtliche
gefühl hätte unser bisheriges
philosophieren übersichtlichkeit wohl
alle sinnlichkeit aufheben müssen und
schreibt in diesem kontext im südlichen
gefühl auch eine art leitungsfunktion zu
jetzt bleibt dann ist noch relativ
schwammig aber also hier das zitat dazu
die vernunft hat bisher bei all ihren
philosophischen vorarbeiten sich selbst
durch begriffe zu leiten versucht aber
nur durch gefühle wirklich sich selbst
geleitet und das finde ich schon
erstaunlich und ich verstehen hier so
dass das was gerade auch diese
leitungsfunktion dass das eben nicht im
sender formal motivierende
leitungsfunktion ist sondern dass es
hier wirklich um unsere überzeugungen um
unseren glauben und um unsere
orientierung geht um den kontakt zur
wirklichkeit ja und so komme ich dann
zum fazit von meinem vom ersten teil das
sind gefühlt reinhold nicht zur
motivation oder ausübung im rollstuhl
handlung bei es ist eine wirkung der
sämtlichen triebfeder
und als solche eine überzeugungs rund
leitungsfunktion und ja das ist der
erste schritt gewesen jetzt und selbst
wenn das so ist stellt sich die frage
was hat das mit kahn zu tun
gerade auch mit blick darauf dass das
ich mich jetzt im ersten teil vor allen
dingen vorrangig auf den siebten brief
gestützt habe und ja man allein schon
deshalb doch den verdacht haben muss das
ist dass es auch hier eine abweichung
gibt von kant insofern die eben dafür
der siebte projekt bekannt ist ich habe
jetzt zwei zitate aufgeführt die das
noch mal sehr schön deutlich machen
1 verlieren donnelley der schreiben dem
in der einleitung schreibt dass reinhold
in dem zweiten band die kann kritik hier
seit 1790 äußert in einer bedeutsamen
weise fortführen dies geschieht
besonders mit dem 708 brief in welchem
die begriffe des willens und events
freiheit erörtert werden
und selbst wenn man dort eben eine
abgrenzung vornehmen könnte kann es eben
sehr gut sein und was mir an diesem
zweiten zitat so schön deutlich finde
ich dass es ganz verstecken und indirekt
hier abweichungen gibt hier darf ich sie
mal eben zitieren weil ich das die
beschreibung wirklich nochmal meine
zweifel so verstärkt hat sein zweiter
brief enthält also versteckt unter dem
gestus der bloßen auslegung eine
eigenständige theorie menschlicher
freiheit also versteckt unter dem gestus
der bloß eine auslegung geben
allerdings bedient sich reinhold aber
immer noch überwiegend der kantischen
terminologie man kann sein als
freiheitsentzug gramm im zweiten brief
bahn deshalb als eine immanente kritik
der rein praktischen vernunft
beschreiben
infolge derer sich unter der hand eine
verschiebung der gesamten kantischen
konstellation freiheits theoretischer
begriff ereignet das ist jetzt die frage
also selbst wenn es markant aussieht ob
da nicht einfach unter der hand ihn
jetzt was untergeschoben wird sozusagen
[Musik]
und auf diese frage möchte ich möchte
ich abschließend über mein kurz eingehen
zum einen ex ethisch ich finde es sehr
sehr auffällig dass es zu all den zu den
bedeutenden bedeutenden argumentationen
zu schritten wirklich deutliche
parallelen stellen gibt so das kann ich
jetzt hier nicht nicht ausführlich
zeigen und nur andeuten aber ebenso wie
ein dass die moralische gefühl
beschreibt oder das sittliche gefühl als
beschreibt das praktische vernunft die
wirkung der ursache geschichtlichen
gefühl zahl dass es vor allem durch
physische eindruck erzeugen empfindung
wesentlich verschieden sei da gibt es
natürlich ganz deutliche belege wie wir
eben zucker schon mit blick auf die
keller voll lesung gehört haben aber
eben auch in den haupt schriften drei
philosophischen schriften kann dann die
definition von leid wir das wohlgefallen
einführt das entspricht teilweise
wortwörtlich auch kann es einführung in
der kritik der urteilskraft in den
ersten paragrafen aber auch in der
kritik der praktischen vernunft oder der
metaphysik der sitten führt er diese
unterscheidung zwischen zwei jahren
praktischer nutzen schon aus die
argumentation die vorgestellt habe gegen
die annahme dass das entweder das eine
oder das andere rolle gefallen also dass
an der boden handlung oder an der
wirklich wirklich eine handlung die
triebfeder sein könnte diese
argumentation findet sich also beide
finden sich recht deutlich auf bei kant
wieder und da wo reinhold den ausdruck
zwecke verwendete verwendet auch kant
den ausdruck zirkel und wo reinhold von
einem wort ohne begriff sprechen spricht
kann von einem widerspruch an sich
selbst widersprechen den unding
ebenso stellen die belegen dass das nach
kant in den mal versucht ortschaften
einzig und allein das moralische gesetz
die triebfeder sein kann lassen sich
anführen also beispielsweise zu
als triebfedern kapitel 12 schreibt dass
die triebfeder des menschlichen willens
niemals etwas anders als das moralische
gesetz sein könne
mithin der objektive bestimmung sgr und
jederzeit und ganz allein
zugleich er subjektiv hinreichende
bestimmung grund der handlung sein müsse
[Musik]
die fiktion des sittlichen gefühls als
bewusstsein der übereinstimmung mit dem
pflicht gesetz dass ich im gefühl
vermögen an kündigt entspricht auch fast
fröhlich kann es definition der des
moralischen gefühls als gemüts anlage
aus der metaphysik der sitten weil man
auch dann noch mal mit blick auf ihre
frage diskutieren können sie inwiefern
ist jetzt gemüts anlage geht es hier um
das vermögen oder und das einzelne
gefühl aber es finden lassen sich
jedenfalls viele übereinstimmungen
finden und ich denke auch dass diese
hochschätzung des gemeinen
menschenverstandes und die beschreibung
von achtung als überzeugungs grund dass
man auch diese position im ersten
abschnitt der grundlegung sehr deutlich
beschrieben findet von cannes wo er eben
doch sehr optimistisch ist bezüglich der
moralische orientierung durch den
gemeinen menschenverstand und das gefühl
der achtung so in verbindung mit dem
gefühl der achtung so aus diesem grund
glaube ich das ist ja ein blick auf
kannst text dass man schon davon
ausgehen könnte dass es sich um eine
kann deutung handeln wird die einheit
hier vorstellt möchte aber noch mal kurz
auf einen systematischen einwand
eingehen wie man haben könnte das ist
jetzt wie gesagt nur eine überlegung zum
systematischen kontext aber eine die ich
noch wichtig finde nämlich die frage ob
es hier eine inhaltliche verzahnung mit
der diskussion um den begriff der
willensfreiheit gibt ja das ist ja
anzunehmen also es hängt ja alles hängt
ja alles zusammen
auch wenn man eben den text zwei teilen
kann den siebten brief aber inhaltlich
ist ja doch verbunden
genau wie bereits angedeutet gerade im
süden brief war reinhold im stark anfang
an mit mit blick auf den begriff des der
freiheit des willens in der welt
vorfindet
also kann fährt häufig auch diese
analytics these zugeschrieben mit blick
auf den abschnitt der grundlegung zur
metaphysik der sitten
insofern dort eben ja teilweise die die
verbindung zwischen die die autonomie
sittliche autonomie und brands freiheit
zu stark miteinander nicht identifiziert
ist nach einer analytischen identitäts
these klingt und dem gegenüber in 23
rollt diese beiden vermögen des willens
und der praktischen vernunft oder dem
sittengesetz und vertritt eine
unabhängigkeit käse das ist jedem um
zwei unabhängige vermögen handelt und
das könnte hier relevant seien insofern
in der argumentation die die reinhold
jetzt mit blick auf die triebfeder frage
vorstellen insofern dort eben die
unterscheidung heraus gesetzt wird
solchen der gesetzmäßigkeit eine
handlung die geschehen soll und der
gesetzmäßigkeit eine handlung die
geschehen ist
der betonte an dieser stelle dass diese
unterscheidung für den gegenstand von
entscheidender bedeutung sei so und da
stellt sich mir dann die frage ob diese
unterscheidung die unabhängigkeit von
reinhold auch voraussetzten wenn wenn
das so ist dann wenn es aus
prinzipiellen gründen jahr
ausgeschlossen dass kant der
argumentation von reinhold mit blick auf
das moralische gefühl überhaupt hätte
zustimmen können so mein gedankengang
und ich würde mich noch mal einen
schuldigen an dieser stelle also ist es
dass ich da nur so oberflächlich darauf
eingehen da könnte man stunden um zu
erzählen und viele andere könnten das
1000 mal besser als ich weiß es sich
vielmehr damit beschäftigt haben als ich
also es ist eben eine große diskussion
um möchte ich möchte damit ganz kurz
darauf eingehen
auf diesen vorwurf des indie label
fatalismus der ursprünglich von schmidt
geäußert wurde auch im 18 jahrhundert
und ja sozusagen kahn vorwirft dass das
in seiner konzeption aus dem aus der
einsicht dass vernunft gesetz eigentlich
immer auch quasi automatisch 100 oder
sogleich mit blick auf die den begriff
der vans freiheit die identifikation
zugleich auch die die moralisch gute
handlung folgen müsste das dann aber
eben die die nichtbefolgung das böse
handeln als freiheitliches ja
prinzipiell unverständlich bleibt so der
vorwurf und mit blick auf diesen diesen
vorwurf könnte es sein dass diese
unterscheidung gar nicht so gemacht
werden kann zwischen der handlung die
geschehen soll und der handlung
geschehen ist allerdings und mehr möchte
ich da jetzt gar nicht darauf eingehen
ich hoffe sie verzeihen mir glaube ich
dass das was man was man das schon
auflösen kann mein vorschlag ist dass
das offen kann team welches freiheit und
autonomie als einheit denkt dass er
trotzdem
[Musik]
diese beiden aspekte unterscheiden kann
also das pflichtbewusstsein von der
pflichterfüllung unterscheiden kann
insofern es sicher auch bei der einheit
die in die kanter denkt immer eine
reflexive ein handeln muss im um selbst
gesetzgebung die eben eine interne
differenz immer schon beinhaltet und ich
glaube jetzt nur mit blick auf diese
argumentationsgrundlage im brief im
ersten teil
die kann man kann problemlos mit gehen
und es spielt keine rolle ob man diese
differenz als interne differenz wie bei
kant oder als externe differenz zwischen
wehr und praktischer vernunft wie bei
reinhold versteht so und deshalb denke
ich dass
kannste zustimmung prinzipiell möglich
wäre und kommen mit blick auf den
zweiten teil zu dem schluss es gibt
ausreichend text belege und es ist
systematisch nicht ausgeschlossen dass
es sich bei 1 thesen zur moralischen
gefühlen um eine handlung handeln könnte
ja ja das finde ich abgesehen davon dass
das ich systematisch aus systematischen
gründen sehr interessiert bin an diesem
thema eine wertschätzung um um ihrer
selbst willen und der rolle von gefühlen
finde es auch historisch einfach
unheimlich spannend also reinhold als
denker und weiß ich doch immer auch die
frage gestellt hat er kann's
philosophien und vereinfacht und bekannt
gemacht sie kritisiert und modifizieren
aber oder in diesem fall eben auch
einfach nur präzisiert genau ich freue
mich dazu auch ihre meinung jetzt fahren
zu können